the union of juts and Drug
Discovery thanks Kia
um for the record uh recursion absorb
veence not the other way around so
veence is part
of no worries um so yeah you've heard
from minutes from yosua and I will be
repeating some of the stuff but
hopefully with a different perspective
Ive and also petition is great um to
learn so um I'll start again with here
you go I think by now you've heard what
A gonet is um I love this slide because
sometimes people come to me and they're
like so gonet that's what kind of
Architecture is that um I guess we did
not choose the name optimally it's not a
neet
architecture but you've heard that
already um
so let's
generative framework where initially we
designed it to sample combinatorial
objects it's still used a lot for that
but um we can now do continuous things
and I think you're going to hear about
that later today um and you know what
are typical Comal objects molecules
that's where we got started with gonets
um but also proteins language uh asan
networks all sorts of things
um
and
um yeah I guess I'll I'll tell you more
about how we came to that um again as
Yosh
mentioned during the pandemic we kind of
through some reinforcement learning at
covid uh hoping to find cool things we
did not find a
antiviral but we did find new algorithms
and that was very fun and the context
setting was basically we doing search
with reinforcement learning we had some
reward function some way to quantify how
good a
particular yes particular uh molecule
was but of course that reward function
was extremely noisy in particular those
familiar with the the context we're
using docking just some kind of uh low
resolution physical simulation of how
let's say a molecule a small molecule
and a protein interact and how much
energy is between them um that's of
course very noisy because it's only an
approximation of physics um and that
meant that you can kind of easily fool
that reward function and and lots of
candidates looked good
um but you know even though lots of
candidates look good it's still a kind
of needle and Hast stack problem you
just have lots of needle your hyack is
10 to the big number and you know uh
finding
really different uh kinds of molecules
that all maybe were interesting
according to that reward was pretty hard
so you know hopefully you you find that
uh set of solutions and you send them to
your wet lab and you get more data to
kind of bootstrap from um but the big
question is what do you want to send and
the traditional way that people have
done this in all sorts of context is
apply some ml generate a batch of can
and then kind of manually or
Hally uh pick the best uh including some
Notions of diversity and that could be
like uh for molecules based on scaffolds
but uh for all sorts of things you may
want to cover your state space
intelligently um but this is all
handcrafting we would like not to have
to do that um so you know the motivation
is what what's a good technique that
finds something diverse by uh
construction and you know why is
diversity important I think josua has
given some pretty convincing arguments I
have more um in organic
chemistry biology uh physics in general
but all sorts of
domains um as I mentioned the the
proxies the reward functions that we
have are very very imprecise they're
sometimes models of models of models um
and so
they can only get you so far right
you're seeing on the right here this
this nice animation of of docking uh a l
at a more kind of refined level here um
and and that's that's really cute and
it's really helpful for someone to
understand what's going on when they're
trying to understand a molecule but it's
really an approximation uh the real
world is more complicated right this
protein might be living in a cell and
being jiggled around by many other
processes right so so um again this this
nice for mode picture that I think
you're going to see a lot
um we want to cast a really wide net you
know if only one of these modes is
actually correct we'd really like uh to
have one candidate in each of these
modes not just for let's say in the same
mode if we're only allowed for picks in
reality of course the the state space
the reward space is is way more complex
you don't have these nice uh easily
separable modes
probably have much worse um so diversity
is is important there kind of by
construction
um another reason I think it's important
that I'm actually working on with other
people is
um we know that new networks can
generalize pretty
well um but that heavily depends on what
data they're trained
on
and as uh we've mentioned you
know the more kind of modes you see the
more combinations of different features
you see
um you would think that a model would
want to go to this different mode
right that's kind of a nice property of
generalization and a nice property of
getting an energy based model to to to
go everywhere um and the neat feature of
gfets is that they have this kind of by
construction right they
as they learn about their reward in
their state space um they induce their
own training distribution because
typically we train them on policy or on
policy adjacent with some exploration
stuff um and so as Chief has learned
they kind of build their own really nice
training distribution which I believe
kind of uh takes fully advantage of the
generalization capabilities of NE
networks that's that's another argument
for diversity um you've heard about RL
and mcmc yesterday um you know can
totally use them to solve these kinds of
problems um so for example for discovery
for molecular design again we have an
mdp right we have actions and rewards um
but exp verion is NRL is very complex
topic and it's really hard and in
practice when we apply our methods we do
tend to see problems with
um as has been
mentioned and same with
mcmc um mode mixing a hard problem
right in in kind of expectation in the
limit uh mcmc gives you the right
solution but you don't want to have to
wait
forever um and we can also use the usual
J generative models
um the kind of downside of this class of
models usually although they are you
know of course extensions but the the
main ones that you've heard a lot about
like the fusion models are are typically
based really on um having a kind of data
set of positive samples right so I show
you million images of cats and get
really good at generating cats um but
for something like like molecules
because we have this scaler reward
instead of this yes this a cat or yes
this is a dog um there's one information
in that scaler or those scalers if
you're doing multiobjective optimization
and we don't want to waste that
information it's really useful
information
so going to do uh some reward portional
model um and of course we want to avoid
doing
mcmc so uh you've seen this before I
think yesterday you see it again sharing
your practical sessions um kind of intro
Comal objects is of course something
like smiley faces where you pick uh am I
going to choose the eyebrow like this or
the smile like this um and the really
important thing to notice is that there
are many ways to build one given face
right so for this evil smiling face
um there's a number of trajectories that
lead to it and it's very important to
account for
that
um again we are in a setting where we
assume that we have some kind of reward
or energy function um and what we're
going to do is use that reward
to associate a flow with each state in
particular for the terminal
States um we're going to think of them
as syncs you can of absorb all this flow
and the initial State here on the left
you can think of it as the unique Source
in your network right and so we end up
with this flow Network the very
important part to kind of get the right
properties that we want that you want
all your flow to be conserved everywhere
um so for example here right you get
three units of flow kind of flowing into
that state um and here for example this
intermediate state only has one unit and
you'll see that if I pause the right
moment um you'll see that it's kind of
split in two because that state has two
parents um and then we combine again
here
and then we combine again
here so you can do that for all your
States um and you end up with a flow
Network that you can use to sample fixes
so how do we do that we Define this
policy that we write PF which if you're
in a some State s to decide which state
to pick next
stastically um you assign a probability
to each transition that is proportional
to the edge flow right so here for a
particular Edge we take the the flow on
that edge and divide by all the other
flows outgoing from that
node and the really neat thing is
mentioned uh this gives us a nice dtive
model
oops
um the the the
ratio here that that we're choosing
induces a really nice distribution where
if all the flows are are preserved of
course the probity of sampling some
particular state is going to be
proportional to the flow that's going
into
it um and then that's of course shly
useful
um maybe I'll stop there again to see if
there are
questions no question so I'm assuming
everyone here
understands great yeah so you know done
this for smiley faces we can do that for
molecules
um here's a really cartoon environment
but in reality we'd have a lot more
things um and so if we have a lot more
things we can't actually you know
instantiate this flow Network in memory
it wouldn't fit um so we have to use
function approximation and we're going
to do just that um typically you know we
use your networks but you can use
anything uh for example for molecules we
can use grafal
networks and what we're going to do or
rather the first thing that we did uh in
the first G paper was to estimate Edge
flows right so you have some Edge um and
typically the prime tracing we would use
is kind of uh give a description of that
state as an input to the function and
that function would output a number of
scalers um one per potential next
state um you might see in the G papers
they're often referred to as actions
that is again some kind of uh
historical
uh you know accident I want to say uh
because we kind of inherited all the RL
terminology while thinking about these
things um it's pretty common in
reinforcement learning to think of I'm
at a state I can take some actions here
are the actions that like go to next
state but you can think of them here for
example as one action being add this new
fragment to this existing
molecule and so
seen it already but hopefully seeing it
again will
help um one way to encode this desire to
train this function proximator is to
think of the constraints that we want
right so given a state we want all the
flow that's coming into it to be equal
to all the flow that's coming out of
it um and then for terminal States in
particular
um
we are assuming that there are sync
States and so we want all the flow that
goes into them to be equal to the reward
again we're assuming here the reward is
given
um the nice thing is that once again if
the those conditions are satisfied and
we're sampling trajectories from this
policy that we've defined then it's
guaranteed that we sample from
the right
distribution so of course the first
reflex is to turn these equations into a
mean squ error uh and this is kind of
exactly what G Zer is doing um actually
for a large enough State space that
would be a terrible idea um so going to
go back a bit here you'll notice that um
at the root right the initial State
actually contains a lot of flow in fact
you might have noticed in the slides I
don't has been very explicitly mentioned
but what you actually recover is that
the flow of the initial state is
actually equal to the partition function
which is the sum of all rewards in your
network um and the bigger network is the
bigger State space is the bigger this
quantity is going to be right so if you
have 10 to the 60 objects um that you're
possible object that you're constructing
and you know uh for a lot of objects
this reward is something non zero the
value of Zed might be extremely
large so if you're taking mean squared
errors here um going to have a bad time
because your network will have much
larger losses for the early States
because they have a lot more flow and uh
will kind of maybe be really good in
some sense predicting their flow but
really bad at predicting the flow of
terminal objects because the losses
there will be extremely
small so what we do instead and I think
what you'll notice we do for basically
all the um G objectives is we operate on
a log
scale and the utility of doing that is
that now the the the value of a mean squ
error on a log scale will be kind of
uh invariant to the scale of the flow
that you're model right so close to the
the leaves close to the terminal States
um the the the difference in log between
two predictions that are wrong will kind
of have uh as significant magnitude than
the loss on the early States
um and that it turns out is is pretty
important to make the whole thing work
um so this this first objective we call
Flow matching and I
think yes there you go
and um know there's some interesting
things about this objective first of all
uh if you do it on the log scale it's
not that bad if you make your newal
network output legits uh then these two
operations are are log sux operations
which can be numerically stable and in
addition you can also use an Epsilon uh
value that you would add to both terms
to kind of stabilize learning here um
actually your Epsilon term here can do
more than just stabilize things um it
can actually you know as I was
mentioning
um give a preference to the the model to
ignore some of the very lowf flow
objects right so
um earlier I was I was saying if you
have uh let's say lots of very small
flows and you're doing a linear mean
squared error the mean squ error will be
tiny um ASAS if you're do it on a log
scale be same everywhere if You' add an
Epsilon after bringing these terms into
a linear scale um if the flows are
really small the rewards are really
small in the case of outflows um then
the Epsilon will kind of bring back
again this mean square area to be really
small so in flow matching that can
actually be used to to help the model
ignore lower reward
States um
second point
is uh so for those familiar with temple
difference methods you might be
wondering why are we you know using the
same
network in the Target and why is it not
detached
um it might be weird to
uh think of it from an RL perspective
because uh we're so used to kind of
thinking of maybe fitted ceration and
stuff like that but here we're doing
something pretty different first of all
uh maybe uh your mdp is deterministic
right so if you think about um the
double sampling issue that Q learning
has you wouldn't have it here because
well you always have the same sample uh
when taking a
transition um and then I think maybe
it's not quite correct to think about it
in terms of RL and temporal difference
because really we're just satisfying
constraints um and and these kind of
locally must make sense and also
globally make sense on top of that
you're using a NE Network which will
generalize right so it makes sense for
kind of both sides of the equation to
inform each other in terms of
loss
um
so once you have the these things
usually you know I think most people
will train a gonet online on policy um
you'll hear later today and I think
tomorrow about more of training gonets
that will do some some exploration or
some offline training on
samples
um but the basic training Loop is uh
very online RL right so you start at the
initial stat you start the smiley face
example um with an empty face and you
take actions to to build an object and
Sample a trajectory using the policy
that you've constructed and then once
the agent says okay I'm done stop uh
receive the reward and then we collect a
bunch of these trajectories and apply
the flow matching objective along that
trajectory
um
because I was mentioning uh you know
this is like the the basic thing to do
there are lots of Tricks here of course
but um
basically
uh yeah one thing I didn't mention of
course but I think yosha mentioned is
that these objectives are off policy
objectives right um as long as you have
a cover of all the state space you don't
need to be following your policy to uh
learn the
correct uh values and that means that if
you have a data set of trajectories or
data set of samples um that can be used
to Trin your model um there's lots of
ways and um you'll hear about this more
but basic way is you know you start with
some high reward objects and you kind of
bias the mini batch of your model to see
more of these objects um
of course doing that will induce some
trade-offs so if you show lots of high
reward objects uh to your model you
might think oh there is you know problem
solv I already kind of found all the
interesting things uh and it might not
learn to explore properly so of course
another kind of off policy you can do is
exploration uh methods there's lots of
them and the kind of basic one that
we've been doing but of course we should
be doing better is this Epsilon online
trick that I think people doing Q
learning and variant are very familiar
with where you basically follow your
policy but with some small Epsilon
chance take a random
action
um this this you know Works H but of
course we can do better
so of course one downside of the flow
matching objective that I just talked
about is that it's very local uh what do
we mean by that
um it only considers you know a single
state in some sense and learns around it
so the state won't be very informed by
the trajectory that it's in or the the
the reward that was part of the
trajectory it was in um this has some
advantages but then at the same time uh
it makes learning very slow because the
the temporal credit assignment has to
kind of propagate slowly from the reward
at end of the terminal States back to
the initial
States another downside of flow matching
is that it's very
expensive um the main reason is because
of these sums so as I mentioned earlier
the typical parameterization of a gfl
net uh that uses these Edge flow
predictions is you train a NE Network
and this NE Network's input is actually
the initial well not the initial state
but the the first state on this Edge
right um and let's say that you know
this state has 100 uh
children so 100 actions um you'll simply
output 100 numbers 100 logits for that
particular
State um sorry yeah so for for the
outflow that's not a problem right um
you have you have one state and and you
just output 100 kind of jits um for the
incoming flow though uh it's a bit more
complicated right so you'll notice here
s is the inputs is on the left hand side
but here s is kind of one of the outputs
and to take the sum here you actually
have to enumerate all the parents of
that state s not only do you have to
enumerate them if there's 100 parents
you have to do 100 forward pass es of
your model to get the edge flow for that
particular Edge um and you know H is not
that bad but in some cases if you're
doing molecular design on the atom level
uh or you're doing natural
language uh in in some funky way um you
can end up with an enormous number of of
parents and that's just not
scalable
um and so
yes um that's
expensive as I mentioned you know this
is related to boost trapping in
reinforcement learning um boost trapping
has a lot of issues
um uh there there can be drift right
because you're you're not drift sorry
bias that induces drift because you're
kind of trusting the prediction of what
happens in the next states that your
model is doing uh and that can lead to a
lot of bias
um and make your model take a very long
time to
learn um so today you'll hear about much
better variants uh that are more
efficient H but also you know less
biased and more
stable you also hear about better
parametrizations so once again the the
parametrization here is on the edge flow
um but all you need is is some way of
getting flows um and you can get that
indirectly by multiplying things uh but
no spoilers you you'll hear about
that and finally um of course as with
any method lots of tricks can
help um some from reinforcement learning
of course uh replay buffers in in
various ways can help
um uh Target networks that you know are
some kind of moving average or or um
kind of old version of your model can
help stabilize sampling or just
learning um you'll also hear about
various forms of intrinsic rewards uh
that may help with learning stability or
exploration um you can
also uh grab tricks from mcmc um there's
a very recent paper that I'm on where
kind of combine gilets and mcmc uh in
very simple way where you kind of start
a trajectory with jonet land somewhere
and because jonet is diverse you kind of
get that diversity for free but then you
can use mcmc to do some kind of local
refinement of your reward and we know
that's going to work because mcmc is is
very good at um
exploration exploring locally within a
reme um you'll feel a lot about
temperature as well um it's very common
that uh if she kind of takes some some
random reward function and some random
setting um the scale of it will be a bit
wrong right so for example uh if in your
state space you have a million objects
um and almost all of them have like 0.5
award and 10 have one reward
um the total mass of the 0.5 reward
objects is still half a million right
and so the probability of sampling those
will be really high a simple trick of
course to kind of lower the probability
of those uh5 reward objects increase the
reward of the one reward objects is to
use the temperature um so one thing that
we've been doing that you'll see again
in papers is just raise the reward to
some exponent beta usually that beta is
some
hyperparameter uh but it can also be uh
part of the input we can learn
temperature conditional models but it's
Al also something that can be scheduled
during
training um other trick that you'll hear
about
uh I won't go too much into it but you
can uh use data sets and Max some
likelihood to do interesting
things um yeah so thank you for
listening and I think I'll take
questions and then Kia will tell you
more about these new objectives that we
have
nice talk Emanuel uh you motivated like
uh G flets and then compared it with ARL
at the beginning right and one of the
challenges you mentioned was like
exploration in RL it wasn't clear to me
how G flets could uh Explore More State
space and then gather more data like
could you yeah um maybe let me go back
to well you know one of the caveats of
RL is that
um at least let's say you're doing soft
you learning which is like nice
maxent uh method you should get uh for
free some proportionality but that
proportionality is a bit pathological if
there are end paths to this say
then the probability of sampling
it kind
of yeah probably sampling it will be
something like number of fats times the
reward proportional to that um you know
for smiley faces is not that bad you
only have like six paths to here but for
a molecule uh that has you
know 50 atoms you have an unfathomable
number of pths um and and this bias will
lead these methods to do weird things um
another Advantage if you compare to just
like even more traditional gdl is that
um some some gdl method might find one
mode and be kind of happy with it
because well it's fine a pretty optimal
policy um and maybe we can get it to
explore but like it takes a while before
the policy learns so I can also go there
uh in contrast jlet wants to do that by
construction there's no built-in
exploration mechanism and it wants to
spread the property Mass everywhere and
that kind of naturally makes it
explore um I don't know if that contrast
them well yeah uh also like um do you
assume like you know like what molecule
fits with what other molecule because if
you don't know then you might have to
explore all combinations to decide like
which ones are fit well which ones don't
and then it kind of like falls down to
the same exploration problem right well
you have to
assume
that your reward contains some
information and that some of this
information can be captured by Network
right so either the reward itself right
so a typical scenario is uh you send 100
molecules to the lab and you get some
reading out of them and then you train
uh
your network random forest or
whatever on those 100 data points and
that gives you some predictions and then
you can feed in new molecules to that NE
Network getting results and you use that
as your reward function and what you do
is is bootstrap from that so you train a
generative model you get maybe 10 new
molecules send them to the wet lab and
then you kind of grow your data set
um but you have to trust that there's
some information in
there so that this model of reward that
you're Capt that you're training
captures something and then that model
has to also have structure so that the G
Net that you're training to you know
Mass reward function can also have some
structure um otherwise of course it's
kind of
hopeless yeah also I was thinking of
distributional LL like U I mean um like
what's special about uh sampling
according to rewards question a and two
can we do this with distributional LL
and get much more with that as compared
to gfet like any thoughts on that let me
start with distribution RL
um distribution RL is about a
parameterization of the value function
it's kind of fundamentally the same
algorithm you're
learning to you know you're learning the
value function of the optimal policy
it's just that in distribution LL
instead of learning the expectation you
learn some distributional form of the
value function uh of the the random
variable that the expectation
is modeling um but you're still learning
the same function uh in gonet you're
learning an entire object entirely a
different object entirely which is about
you know energy based sty
model um can you you could on sorry you
could potentially sample uh actions once
you have the distribution or value
function or the value of the state you
can potentially sample actions using any
of the uh metrics right not just
expected value maybe would want to
sample like um like quartiles based
actions or things like that which kind
of gives you like diverse policies
essentially
right
uh I not sure that's correct but I'm not
a distribution LL expert one thing I do
know is distribution give you something
like risk or risk policies because you
can look at the variance let's say of
the value prediction of different
actions and pick the one that's high W
and low variance but I don't know
about using that for diversity because
uh the best diversity you'd get is
diversity of rewards so you could do the
inverse of risk RSE you can do
risk-seeking right you pick the action
that has the most variants um but then
that just means you might sample low
reward actions
um here you can you know still sample
High uh objects is just because of the
smoothness
um
you you have this diversity by
default I
don't hi I have a very naive question
okay so I specialize in physics and I'm
not an expert in this field but um in
physics when we look at flows you know
in nature we also can have back flows so
I'm wondering why are all your like
transfer of information in one specific
Direction yeah I guess here we're just
using flow as a very convenient analogy
yeah um not too familiar with what a
backflow might be
um I
think so so here we kind of designed
these flow networks to be asy DS that's
very convenient because then we don't
have to think about of edge cases
you could actually have Cycles in here
yeah that's what I'm taking yeah
um it would uce some problems but I we
think we can fix those problems without
too much difficulty
um for me it just seems that you're you
would add another dimension like you
would add more exploration so it would
might be
logic yeah I I'm curious to know what a
backflow is but maybe come see me at the
break
thanks thanks Emanuel for the great talk
so I just wanted to go back to the slide
that we were describing how we can train
gonet offline uh so you mentioned that
uh maybe we can initiate the samples
that have high rewards but what if we
don't have access to that you know um
har bar samples yeah so uh something
that works fairly well is a replay
buffer where you only keep your top end
samples right right and then that that
kind of accounts as uh leveraging a data
set is just your data set is
dynamic that works pretty well but then
there is this trade-off sometimes of if
you're too too greedy to high reward
with the data that you show your model
then
okay yeah but so what if okay so I
understand that you know replay buffer
actually keeps the um you can have some
sort of a priority in your replay buffer
and keep the samples exct high regards
but what if we actually you know like
there's a scenario that um we cannot
assign rewards to those
trajectories um and maybe you can do
some sort of uh clustering and just you
know figure out what samples have more
values to the task that you are trying
to
solve um are you saying if you don't
even have a word function what can you
do yeah okay so I mean uh we
have some results where if you have a
data set you can do the energy based
thing BAS Bally and uh learn the energy
function as you're training your
sampler that that's totally fair game um
you were talking about clusters maybe
you could if you don't have a data set
but you have some notion of distance
between samples you could use that
distance
information clustering information to
build an energy function or W function I
think that would also be fair game um as
long as it's consistent with the problem
you're
solving yeah should be fine okay thank
you so yes I had a similar question
related to the one before um like why
are you what are the reasons of using
flow instead of weights for example no
it's like to apply the condition that
the input has equal the output of flow
or or is there any other reason like for
using flow instead of Weights you
know I mean the the the flow is just a
metaphor yeah um there's there's not a
the physical interpretation here it's
really just a convenient way to to think
about the maybe or to explain the
concept I was like curious about it you
know because usually we see like weights
in the Neal networks well so but you are
defining like the ratio flow that could
be also like the same concept no so like
you know this this
is this is a a flow network but not a NE
Network right yeah um
we never actually see this graph
anywhere like we don't instantiate it in
the program it's only
implicit in the fact that we have an
agent that can like build faces right
okay so what what the ne Network sees
let's say is like a face and it makes
predictions about that face particular
here for the the empty face it makes uh
six predictions which kind of tell it
which action to pick which next phas to
go
to yeah more reward than okay okay
okay you think you
then a quick question regarding the
training you said this was done online I
wonder how this like does this mean that
for each for example given molecule
you're going to have like one online
learning pass or is there a way to like
Leverage the fact that different
molecule columns might have
similarities like aside from the reward
function uh try get your question so
like basically are we just like when you
learn online like this is it like one
sort of online learning task for each
different molecule you're trying to
learn yeah so one thing we assume is
that the the reward function is somewhat
cheap to compute and if it's not cheap
like you have to send something to
wetlab then you can train a proxy for
it they're always around that but they
all kind of in my opinion equivalent to
training a proxy for it and then yeah so
you're just seeing a molecule training
on it then you kind of throw away that
data because you want to learn about
different molecules so basically like
it's more the compute time than the data
you really want to go like one example
at a time or like one problem at a time
but you're going to just like I don't
know use as many compute Cycles as
possible and hopefully you're going to
like converge towards like bright
distribution yeah that's correct
okay thank you for the talk Manuel so I
had a question concerning the structure
of the gonet like I was wondering what
is the advantage of um having many
trajectories that lead to the same
terminal States instead of of having a
tree for your Gess because like one one
helps to share information but is also
makes the problem more complex because
you have to learn more things yeah I
think that's actually interesting
research question um so there's two
things one
is um for something like a molecule or
smiley face we could uh canonicalize the
order in which you build it right so we
could always choose the left eyebrow
first then choose the sorry the right
eyebrow first then the left eyebrow then
the mouth then we would have a treat say
um sometimes that's actually really hard
to do uh for very symmetric
objects like molecules for example that
you Define atom by atom uh there's not a
good way to canonically build them such
that you'll end up with an mdp that's
always a
tree
um let's say you're you're building this
little triangle here um well actually I
don't know if that's a good example but
um I think sorry I'm trying to think of
an example on the spot but like
um if you're building this ring
um here like a neat canonical form would
be you always have to start with the
oxygen and then the other carbon atoms
but like for more complex molecules
that's not always possible and you end
up with different versions of the same
thing depending on which of these carbon
atoms you start
with um and in the general case you
can't enforce well easily maybe you can
but it's a very complicated fistic and
complex masking but as far as I know um
and people in chemistry have been
thinking about this a lot for something
like Smiles it's really hard to build
kind of a unique sequence that
describes one
object um but another related question I
think for gonus in particular is that uh
something that we'll be discussed a bit
later is um there's implicitly here some
kind of backboard allocations of the
flow here I kind of did some thing where
everything is equal but you could
possibly train a network to say no I
only want to care about one parent at a
time then you'd kind of end up
withu but I I don't know if anyone's
investigated that
properly yeah I have a question about
the the concept of the flow because I
come from the orl background so for me
this kind of looks like just a value
function but your discount Factor sets
one I was wondering if you ever
experienced with oh if it's possible to
have this a discount Factor where your
your inflow is equal to like gamma of
your outflow like have this concept of
discounted flows if it even if it breaks
your training or not and would you even
be interested in thatth is discounting
even relevant in terms of generating
data I want to say no but I think some
people have thought about this more
deeply than I uh so I'll redirect you to
them so come see me after thank
you hi thanks for the talk um I'm
curious if empirically you have any
observations regarding the number of
samples needed for trading relative to
the number of terminal states in the
problem is there any like relation there
or is it the number of samples to like
converge yeah uh it's really problem
dependent I guess these are not cheap
methods um like training on the
simplified fragment environment molecule
uh it can take you know six hours to
start getting decent results and like
I've train model for days and they still
have not converged they're still
learning and discovering new things um
but I think it's really going to be
problem dependence
thanks probably last question make it
quick
maybe uh I was wondering uh there's this
assumption in in making the U
in composing uh the smiley face for
example uh there's no difference in uh
first doing the left eyebrow than the
right eyebrow so uh what if there was a
slight difference instead of uh
there could be no difference assumtion
and there could be a large difference in
which case we wouldn't have a de what if
there was a slight uh
difference yeah I mean this is the case
in like fragments um depending on uh see
you're doing chemical synthesis kind of
environments depending on the order when
which you do things you'll get different
results uh that that's true and there's
there's ways to handle that you just
have to represent your state in the
right way so that when give it as an
input to network it knows that the
differences are there but
yeah very quickly what is the trade-off
in terms of how you split up your action
space so you could for instance have uh
maybe like just a very like a large
number of possible paths but with like
only a few actions so few parents or you
have a very complex action so you have
lots of parents but you have kind of
less
States in your intermediate States what
is the kind of tradeoff in training
complex that's a very good question um
and I think this deserves more study
because there are some cases where we've
done that experiment so let's say you're
generate a sequence and you only have
like four
tokens you could have four actions or
and generate one token or two or 16
actions during to so you can think of
all the the lengths and if you do that
there doesn't seem to be that much
difference which is
surprising um but in some other
environments where we're generating
graphs um the like the way you you give
choices to the agent does seem to matter
um sometimes very negatively if you're
not careful um and I think that's
something that should be studied more in
reinforcement learning how to design an
mdp thank
you